I sometimes get criticism from a
listener here and there that while
having a conversation with a world-class
mathematician physicist neurobiologist
aerospace engineer or theoretical
computer scientists like yourself I
waste time by asking philosophical
questions about freewill consciousness
mortality love nature of truth super
intelligence whether time travel is
possible whether space-time is emergent
fundamental even the crazy questions
like whether aliens exist what their
language might look like what their math
might look like whether math is inventor
discovered and of course whether we live
in a simulation or not so I'd write with
it out with it I try to dance back and
forth from the deep technical to the
philosophical so I've done that quite a
bit so you're a world class computer
scientist and yet you've written about
this very point the philosophy is
important for experts in any technical
discipline though they somehow seem to
avoid this so I thought it'd be really
interesting to talk to you about this
point why should we computer scientists
mathematicians physicists care about
philosophy do you think well I would
reframe the question a little bit I mean
philosophy almost by definition is the
subject that's concerned with the
biggest questions that you could
possibly ask all right so you know the
ones you mentioned right are are we
living in a simulation you know are we
alone in the universe how should we even
think about such questions you know is
the future determined and what you know
what do we even mean by it being
determined why are we alive at the time
we are and not at some other time you
know and and and you know when you when
you sort of contemplate the enormity of
those questions I think you know you
could ask well then why why be concerned
with anything else right why why not
spend your whole life on those questions
you know I think I think in some sense
that is the the right way to phrase the
question and you know and and and
actually you know what what we learned
you know I mean throughout history but
really starting with
scientific revolution we've got you know
Galileo and so on is that there is a
good reason to you know focus on
narrower questions you know more
technical you know mathematical or
empirical questions and that is that you
can actually make progress on them right
and you can actually often answer them
and sometimes they actually tell you
something about the philosophical
questions that sort of you know may be
motivated your curiosity as a child
right you know they don't necessarily
resolve the philosophical questions but
sometimes they reframe your whole
understanding of them right and so for
me philosophy is just the thing that you
have in the background from the very
beginning that you want to you know you
know these are these are sort of the
reasons why you went into intellectual
life in the first place
at least the reasons why I did right but
you know math and science are tools that
we have for you know actually making
progress and you know hopefully even you
know changing our understanding of these
philosophical questions sometimes even
more than philosophy itself does what
what do you think computer scientists
avoid these questions will run away from
them a little bit at least in technical
scientific discourse well I'm not I'm
not sure if they do so more than any
other scientists though I mean I mean I
mean I mean I mean Alan Turing was
famously you know interested and you
know his his most famous one of his two
most famous papers was in a philosophy
journal mind you know it was the one
where he proposed the Turing test he
took Vidkun Stein's course at Cambridge
you know argued with him I just recently
learned that a little bit and it's
actually fascinating I I was I was
trying to look for resources in trying
to understand where the sources of
disagreement and debates between
Wittgenstein and touring war
that's an interesting that these two
minds of somehow met in the arc of
history
yeah well the transcript you know of
their the course which was a 1939 right
is one of the more fascinating documents
that I've ever read because you know a
Vidkun Stein is trying to say well
all of these these formal systems are
just a complete irrelevance is right if
a formal system is irrelevant who cares
you know why does that matter in real
life right and touring is saying well
look you know if you use an inconsistent
formal system to design a bridge you
know the bridge might make collapse
right and you know so so touring in some
sense is thinking decades ahead you know
I think of where Vidkun Stein is the way
with formal systems are actually going
to be used you know in computers right
to actually do things in the world you
know and it's interesting that touring
actually dropped the course
halfway through why because he had to go
to Bletchley Park and you know work on
something of more immediate importance
that's fascinating
if you take a step from philosophy to
actual like the biggest possible step to
actual engineering the actual real
impact yeah and I would say more
generally right a uh you know a lot of
scientists are you know interested in
philosophy but they're also busy right
and they have you know a lot on their
plate and there are a lot of sort of
very concrete questions that are already
you know not answered but you know look
like they might be answerable right and
so then you could say well then why you
know break your brain over these you
know metaphysically unanswerable
questions when there were all of these
answerable ones instead so I think you
know for me I I enjoy talking about
philosophy I even go to philosophy
conferences sometimes such as the you
know fqx eye conferences I enjoy
interacting with philosophers I would
not want to be a professional
philosopher because I like being in a
field where I feel like you know uh you
know if I get too confused about the
sort of eternal questions then I can
actually make progress on something can
you maybe linger on that for just a
little longer yeah what do you think is
the difference so like the corollary of
the criticism that I mentioned
previously that why ask the
philosophical questions of the
mathematician is if you want to ask
falafels questions then invite a real
philosopher on and
ask them so what's the difference
between the way a computer scientist and
mathematician Ponder's a philosophical
question and a philosopher Ponder's the
philosophical question well I mean I
mean a lot of it just depends on the
individual all right it's hard to make
generalizations about entire fields but
you know I think I think if we if we if
we tried to we tried to stereotype you
know we would say that uh you know as
scientists very often will be less
careful in their use of words you know I
mean philosophers are really experts in
sort of you know like when it when it
when I talk to them and they will just
pounce if you know use the wrong phrase
for something versus a very nice word
you could say cyclers yeah yeah or you
know they will they will sort of
interrogate my word choices let's say to
a much greater extent than scientists
would write and and scientists you know
will often if you ask them about a
philosophical problem like the hard
problem in of consciousness or freewill
or whatever they will try to relate it
back to you know recent research right
you know research about about
neurobiology or you know but you know
the best of all was research that they
personally are involved with right right
and you know and and and and you know of
course they will want to talk about that
you know and it is what they will think
of you know and then of course you could
have an argument that maybe you know
it's all interesting as it goes but
maybe none of it touches the
philosophical question right but you
know but maybe um you know as a science
you know at least it it as I said it
does tell us concrete things and you
know even if like a deep dive into
neurobiology will not answer the hard
problem of consciousness you know maybe
it can take us about as far as we can
get toward you know expanding our minds
about it you know toward thinking about
it in a different way
well I mean I think neurobiology can do
that but you know with these profound
philosophical questions I mean also art
and literature do that right they're all
different ways of trying to approach
these questions that you know we don't
for which we don't even know
really what an answer would look like
but and yet somehow we can't help but
keep returning to the questions and you
have a kind of mathematical beautiful
mathematical way of discussing this with
the idea of Q Prime oh you're right they
usually the only way to make progress on
the big questions like the full of the
philosophical questions we're talking
about now is to pick off smaller sub
questions
ideally sub questions you can attack
using math empirical observation or both
you define the idea of a Q prime so
given an unanswerable philosophical
riddle q replace it with a mirror leak
in quote scientific or mathematical
question Q prime which captures part of
what people have wanted to know when
they first asked q yes then with luck
once all Q prime so you described some
examples of such q prime sub questions
in your long essay titled white
philosophers should care about
computational complexity so you
catalogue the various Q Prime's on which
you think of theoretical computer
science has made progress can you
mention a few favorites if any pop any
pop to mind or yes so I mean I would say
some of the most famous examples in
history of that sort of replacement well
you know I mean I mean to go back to
Alan Turing right what he did in his
Computing Machinery and intelligence
paper was exactly you know he explicitly
started with the question can machines
think and then he said sorry I think
that question is too meaningless but
here's a different question you know
could you program a computer so that you
couldn't tell the difference between it
and a human right and you know yeah in
the very first few sentences he in fact
just yeah I miss the Q prime precise he
does precisely that or you know we could
look at at girdle right where you know
you had these philosophers arguing for
centuries about the limits of
mathematical reasoning right in the
limits of formal systems and you know
them by the early 20th century logicians
you know starting with you know frag a
Russell and then you know most
spectacularly girdle you know man
to reframe those questions as look we
have these formal systems they have
these definite rules are there questions
that we can phrase within the rules of
these systems that are not provable
within the rules of the systems and can
we prove that fact right and so that
would be another example you know III
had this essay called the ghost in the
quantum Turing machine that's you know
one of the crazier things I've written
but I I tried to do something you know
to advocate doing something similar
therefore free will where you know
instead of talking about is free will
you know real where we get hung up on
the meaning of you know what exactly do
we mean by freedom and can you have can
you be you know or do we mean
compatibilist free will libertarian free
will what are these things mean you know
I suggested just asking the question how
well in principle consistently with the
laws of physics could a person's
behavior be predicted
you know without so let's say destroying
the person's brain you know taking it
apart in the process of trying to
predict them and you know and that
actually asking that question gets you
into all sorts of meaty and interesting
issues you know issues of what is the
computational substrate of the brain you
know or can you understand the brain you
know just at the sort of level of the
neurons you know it's sort of the
abstraction of a neural network or do
you need to go deeper to the you know
molecular level ultimately even to the
quantum level right and of course that
would put limits on predictability if
you did so you need to reduce you need
to reduce the mind to a computational
device like formalize it so then you can
make predictions about what you know
whether you could predict a B if you
were trying to predict a person yeah
then presumably you would need some
model of their brain right and now the
question becomes one of how accurate can
such a model become can you make a model
that will be accurate enough to really
seriously threaten people's sense of
free will you know not just
metaphysically but like really I've
written in this envelope what you were
going to say next it's not the right
term here so
well it's also a level of abstraction
has to be right so if you're yeah if
you're accurate at the somehow at the
quantum level hmm
that may not be convincing to us at the
human level well right but the question
is what accuracy at the sort of level of
the underlying mechanisms do you need in
order to predict the behavior right at
the end of the day the test is just can
you you know foresee what the person is
going to do right I am you know and and
and and you know and and and and in
discussions of freewill you know it
seems like both sides want to you know
very quickly dismiss that question is
irrelevant well to me it's totally
relevant okay because you know if
someone says oh well you know I will
applause demon that knew the complete
state of the universe you know could
predict everything you're going to do
therefore you don't have free will you
know that it doesn't trouble me that
much because well you know I've never
met such a demon hey you know uh you
know and we you know we even have some
reasons the thing you know maybe it you
know it could not exist this part of our
world you know it was only an
abstraction a thought experiment on the
other hand if someone said well you know
I have this brain scanning machine you
know you step into it and then you know
every paper that you will ever write it
will write you know every thought that
you will have you know even right now
about the machine itself it will force a
you know a well if you can actually
demonstrate that then I think you know
that that you know that that sort of
threatens my internal sense of having
free will in a much more visceral way
you know but now you notice that we're
asking in a much more empirical question
we're asking is such a machine possible
or isn't it if it's not possible then
what in the woes of physics or what
about the behavior of the brain you know
prevents it from existing so if you
could philosophize a little bit within
this empirical question at where do you
think would enter the the by which
mechanism would enter the possibility
that we can't predict the outcome so
there would be something they'll be akin
to a free will yeah well you could say
the the sort of obvious possibility
which was you know
cognized by Addington and many others
about as soon as quantum mechanics was
discovered in the 1920s was that if you
know let's say a sodium ion channel you
know in the in the in in in the brain
right hey today you know it's its
behavior is chaotic right it sort of
it's governed by these hodja hodja li
hot skin equations in neuroscience right
which are differential equations that
have a stochastic component right now
where does you know and this ultimately
governs let's say whether a neuron will
fire or not that's a basic chemical
process or electrical process by which
signals are sent in the brain exactly
exactly and and you know and so you
could ask well well where does the
randomness in the process you know that
that neuroscientists you're but what
neuroscientists would would treat is
randomness where does it come from you
know ultimately it's thermal noise right
where does thermal noise come from but
ultimately you know there were some
quantum mechanical events at the
molecular level that are getting sort of
chaotically amplified but you know a
sort of butterfly effect and so you know
even if you knew the complete quantum
state of someone's brain you know at
best you could predict the probabilities
that they would do one thing or do
another thing right I think that part is
actually relatively uncontroversial
right the the the controversial question
is whether any of it matters for the
sort of philosophical questions that we
care about because you could say if all
it's doing is just injecting some
randomness into an otherwise completely
mechanistic process well then who cares
right and more concretely if you could
build a machine that you know could just
calculate the even just up the
probabilities of all the possible things
that you would do all right and you know
um you know if all the things that said
you had a 10% chance of doing you did
exactly a tenth of them you know and and
and and and and so on that somehow also
takes away the feeling of free exactly I
mean I mean to me it seems essentially
just as bad as if the Machine
deterministically predicted you it seems
you know
are we different from that so that so
then but a more a more subtle question
is could you even learn enough about
someone's brain to do that okay because
you know another central fact about
quantum mechanics is that making a
measurement on a quantum state is an
inherently destructive operation okay so
you know if I want to measure the you
know position of a particle right it was
well before I measure it it had a
superposition over many different
positions as soon as I measure I
localized it right so now I know the
position but I've also fundamentally
changed the state and so so you could
say well maybe in trying to build a
model of someone's brain that was
accurate enough to actually you know
make let's say even even well calibrated
probabilistic predictions of their
future behavior maybe you would have to
make measurements that were just so
accurate that you were just
fundamentally alter their brain okay or
or or or maybe not maybe you only you
know you it would suffice to just make
some nano robots that just measured some
sort of much larger scale you know
macroscopic behavior like you know is
that you know what is this neuron doing
what is that neuron doing maybe that
would be enough see but now you know III
but what I claim is that we're now
asking a question you know in which you
know it is it is it is possible to
envision what progress on it would look
like yeah but just as you said that
question may be slightly detached from
the philosophical question in the sense
if consciousness somehow has a role to
the experience of free will because
ultimately what we're talking about free
will we're also talking about not just
the predictability of our actions but
somehow the experience of them
predictability yeah well I mean a lot of
philosophical questions ultimately like
feedback to the hard problem of
consciousness you know and as much as
you can try to sort of talk around it or
not right and you know and then and and
there is a reason why people try to talk
around it which is that you know
Democritus
talked about the hard problem of
consciousness you know in 400 BC
terms that would be totally recognizable
to us today right and it's really not
clear if there's been progress since or
what progress could possibly consist of
is there a cute prime type of sub
question that could help us get it
consciousness it's something about
Connie oh well I mean well I mean there
is the whole question of you know of AI
right of you know can you build a human
level or superhuman level AI and you
know can it can it work in a completely
different substrate from the brain I
mean there's you know of course that was
Alan Turing's point and you know and and
and even if that was done it's you know
maybe people would still argue about the
hard problem of consciousness right and
yet you know my claim is a little
different my claim is that in a world
where you know there were you know
human-level AI is where we'd been even
overtaken by such a eyes the entire
discussion of the hard problem of
consciousness would have a different
character
right it would take place in different
terms in such a world even if we hadn't
answered the question and and my claim
about free will would be similar right
that if there if this prediction machine
that I was talking about could actually
be built
well now the entire discussion of the
you know a free will is sort of
transformed by that you know even if in
some sense the the metaphysical question
hasn't been answered yeah exactly
transforms it fundamentally because say
that machine does tell you that it can
predict perfectly and yet there is this
deep experience of free will and then
that changes the question completely
yeah and it starts actually getting to
the question of the a the a GI the
touring questions if the demonstration
of free will the demonstration of
intelligence the demonstration of
consciousness does that equal
nauseousness intelligence and free will
but see elects if every time I was
contemplating a decision you know this
machine had printed out an envelope you
know where I could open it and see that
it knew my decision I think that
actually would change my subjective
experience of making decisions you might
mean doesn't knowledge change your
subjective experience well well you know
I mean I mean the knowledge that this
machine had
everything I would do I mean it might
drive me completely insane right but at
any rate it would change my experience
to AG you know to not just discuss such
a machine as a thought experiment but to
actually see it yeah I mean I mean you
know you could say at that point you
know you could say you know what why not
simply call this machine a second
instantiation of MIDI and be done with
it right what we are what what why even
privilege the original me over this
perfect duplicate that that exists in
the machine
yeah or there could be a religious
experience with a Jew it's kind of what
God throughout the generations is
supposed to have that God kind of
represents that perfect machine is able
to I guess actually well I I don't even
know what a work what are the religious
interpretations of freewill yeah does so
if God knows perfectly everything in in
religion in the various religions word
is free will fit into that do you know
that has been one of the big things that
theologians have argued about for
thousands of years you know I am I am
NOT a theologian and maybe I shouldn't
go there there's not a clear answer in a
book like I mean I mean this is you know
the Calvinists debated this the you know
this has been you know I mean different
religious movements have taken different
positions on that question but that is
how they think about it you know
meanwhile you know a large part of sort
of what what animates you know
theoretical computer science you could
say is you know we're asking sort of
what are the ultimate limits of you know
what you can know or you know calculate
or figure out by you know entities that
you can actually build in the physical
world right and if I were trying to
explain it to a theologian maybe I would
say you know we are studying you know to
what extent you know gods can be made
manifest in the physical world I'm not
sure my colleagues would like that
you